tras el descubrimiento de decenas de
cadáveres de civiles en la ciudad de
lucha bruselas quiere ser contundente un
quinto paquete de sanciones que
aumentará la presión sobre moscú entre
los propuestos por la comisión europea
prohibición de todas las importaciones
de carbón de rusia una fuente de energía
más fácil de sustituir que el petróleo o
el gas ruso otra propuesta el cese total
de las transacciones con cuatro grandes
bancos rusos que representan un cuarto
del sector bancario otra propuesta es la
de prohibir el acceso de los barcos
rusos a los puertos europeos salvo los
que transportan productos esenciales su
ayuda humanitaria está claro que a la
vista de los acontecimientos debemos
aumentar nuestra presión
así que hoy proponemos ir más allá con
nuestras sanciones las ampliaremos y las
haremos más precisas así afectarán aún
más a la economía rusa
para que se adopten las sanciones los
estados miembros de la unión europea
deben votar por unanimidad los
representantes de los 27 debatirán las
propuestas el miércoles
de una reunión de ministros de asuntos
exteriores de la unión europea el
próximo lunes por el lado estadounidense
la misma voluntad de endurecer el tono
contra moscú washington prohibir a el
miércoles todas las nuevas inversiones
en rusia para ello las autoridades
reforzarán las sanciones contra las
instituciones financieras las empresas
públicas rusas y los funcionarios del
gobierno y sus familiares de pérez la
mayor parte de nuestro objetivo es
agotar los recursos que tiene putin para
continuar su guerra contra ucrania y
obviamente crear más incertidumbre y
desafíos al sistema financiero ruso es
parte de su sistema verdad según una
fuente estadounidense se espera que la
economía rusa se contraiga al menos un
15 por ciento en 2022 como consecuencia
de la guerra en ucrania y las sanciones
occidentales una recesión que borraría
los progresos económicos realizados por
el país en los últimos 15 años